now you've been dealing with functions a
lot right just like I said you didn't
necessarily know it if I didn't put that
all exit there you know I know that is
ok it's a parabola you deal with ok
let's think about some other functions
that you know ok let's stay in the
mathematical world for instance if I
asked you so here's a careful too if I
asked you to write for me the area of a
circle area oh so you guys know there's
a formula for the area of a circle right
but the formula is just a function right
it's just a connection between area and
arian what what's the other variable
it's connected to it's just radius right
so I would usually write a equals PI R
squared right but using my function
notation I'll write it slightly
differently I would say a of our right a
is a function of our a depends on up and
then I would write there's pie R square
power squared is the action kind of
funny now once you see this right and
unlocks a whole different way of talking
about all kinds of things area is a
function of radius I could say you know
is I'm not even gonna a lot even bother
writing this one but um the function
that is our tax tax is a function like
how much tax I pay is a function of how
much money I earn right and we give that
a name we call that income now the
reason why i put this one is because you
know functions can be very simple like
just a few a few characters right but
sometimes functions are wildly
complicated fact do I have it here all
right let's see
love ya 29
it's a little bit
can you see see that like enormous
awkward table that you've seen before up
their taxable income tax on this new car
it's long and it's complicated that it
that's a function it's a messy function
right but all it does is it takes two
variables it takes an input you tell me
how much money you earn and I'll give
you an output I'll tell you how much the
government is scraping off you right
it's a simple connection between two
variables right um independent and
dependent okay let me give you a couple
of other ones that you're all familiar
with just to extend this a little bit um
I've given you one two three examples
where there is one dependent variable
and one independent variable but as you
know lots of things in life and lots of
things in mathematics they don't just
depend on one value at the end one value
about the end right for instance I'm
area of a circle the volume of a
cylinder here's another engine right
what's the formula for the volume of a
cylinder it's PI R squared H and and in
the height of this thing right so when I
write V volume is not just a function of
radius it's also a function of height
and it's not just one or the other it's
both at the same time so not that you
need to necessarily it is for the next
test is coming up but it's a natural
extension of this volume is a function
of r and h that's all it means right
volume needs you need to give me two
numbers right you need to give me two
input and then i'll tell you the output
and of course it's like you see on PI R
squared H right how about I'm not even
gonna write the definition of this one
if I bet a car right I don't want to
know how far have I traveled what's the
distance travel zone that's right what
is distance thinking your science head
right physics what's distance a function
of what two inputs are going to put in
turn out I need speed at any time right
so i would say distance is a pump your
speed and time right it's a very simple
one it's just speed time started
60.com is an hour traveling for 3 hours
3 and x 6500 many qualities at how far
you've gone okay so this is a simple
simple idea right and this is how
everybody now I would come back to my
very first example because our X's and
Y's are we going to spend most of our
time okay there's a natural way to think
about this and actually not just
thinking about like all these hairy
fairy abstract who knows what these
things are equal to you right but I can
think of these as I can think of this
notation as a tool for you subheading
substituting and evaluating substituting
and eval you so if I come back to this
guy right y of x equals x squared minus
5 ok just humor me right if I wrote down
this the first line says y of X is that
what would you read that as you wouldn't
say Y of X you would say why of 11 right
way what and everywhere you see an X
you're just going to put a 1 instead
yeah so this would be 1 squared take
away 5 which is just negative 4 okay now
what does this mean what am I just done
here two things I've substituted in a
value of x I swapped out I've switched
out all my exes for ones if I had like
more x terms over here like x squared
minus 3x minus 5 all of those X's are
there i'd also put one's in there ok so
i've substituted and then secondly i've
evaluated ok I've gone and crunched the
numbers and that's what I've got ok so
another way of reading that we said why
I want that's correct but another way of
reading that is when X is 1 what's y
equals
when x equals 1 y equals what that's
what this question is answered this
answer is quickly whatever you okay
that's that's what you're interested in
and correspondingly this is giving you
coordinates you see this is giving you
coordinates is giving you a pair of
numbers what's the X that I've got just
one and the corresponding Y value write
the output up getting is negative 4 so
one negative 4 is a point on my curve
right just a bee I'm going there you go
so all I'm doing is is popping in
numbers now I can do this for anything
like i like i can do for a while one I
can do for why have a hundred i can even
do it for more algebra if that's useful
too for instance if i say what's this
equal to Y of 2a well it's asking
where'd x is equal to 2a what's y equal
to okay so all i need to do is just like
I did before straight substitution right
let's see here I've got to a in the
squared take away 5 right look the
brackets okay they're really important
because the whole thing is getting
squared right what is to whisper in a
forest moment so I don't know what that
value is that's cuz I don't know what
age if I did I would just pop that in
now I know that to a 4a squared mines
fine that's also a point that's on my
parabola I've no idea where it is
because I don't know what a is but that
point for any value of a is going to be
a point of my problem right